as it relates to
movies cartoons comedy
Netflix
music social media there's not a
platform except that they have entered
into that platform why because they
strategic they look at graphs they look
at
charts where can we be most
powerful where can we have the greatest
impact let's go through comedy let's go
through
movies right let's go through these
different Avenues Kevin Hart and the
likes and the biggest the biggest
promoter of L the LGBT movement in the
black community amongst actors is Kevin
Hart is Kevin
Hart and you have Muslims that say I
love Kevin Hart he's so funny Subhan
Allah he doesn't make a move except that
he's he promoted within the
movie and not that I'm aware of that
except that you see the articles online
it's intended neck flex doesn't have a
short except that it's there my dear
brothers and sisters this remind us of a
very important
point and that is when our
lordal prevents
us when our Lord prevents us from
something whether we understand the
wisdom or not we
submit whether we understand the wisdom
or not we submit Allah said in the
Quran Allah does not want to make things
difficulty difficult for
you right Allah
says Allah wants to forgive you
Allah says Allah wants to forgive
you and those who follow their desires
they want you to go far
astray those who follow their desires
astray wonderful statement ofik ABD one
of the great Scholars of our time
of he
said
he said it's upon the
bevers to understand and contemplate
over the wisdom in what Allah has
legislated when Allah legislates
something it's for our benefit Allah is
not preventing us from something except
that it has a harm or a greater harm a
complete harm or a greater
harm a complete harm or a greater
harm so when the scholars spoke about
music and now you have female and male
magicians gays and lesbians and
supporting it and when the scholars
spoke about cartoons or when the
scholars spoke about other things right
it was upon the Believers to submit
because it either has complete harm or
it has greater harm either complete harm
or a greater
harm right
likewise the prophet Muhammad s Al said
is
reported the prophet said whatever I
have forbidden you stay away from
it whatever I have forbidden stay away
from
it my dear brothers and sisters Allah is
Allah is the all
knowing Allah
is Allah is the all
wise so when Allah has forbidden
something for us it's through his
wisdom it's through his
knowledge
says Allah gives a rhetorical
question in the Quran Allah says is
Allah more knowledgeable or are
you or are you so when Allah has
forbidden something upon us it's because
it has complete danger or or more danger
than harm or more danger than
harm we have to remember the statement
of
Allah
said Allah swore by
himself Allah Asel swore by himself they
do not
believe until they make the prophet the
judge in their
Affairs so whatever and then what Allah
says until they make you a judge in
their Affairs then they do not find any
hesitation or reluctance in what you
have decreed and they submit
wholeheartedly so my dear brothers and
sisters the reason why I mention this is
because whatever is forbidden in Islam
we avoid it because it's harmful for us
whether we realize and whether we do not
it's mentioned by IM also a great
scholar of T of our time and he's the
teacher of many of our great Scholars
the likes of he's the teacher of shik
fad he's the teacher ofik he's the
teacher
of he's the teacher of and
others said pay attention very important
statement he
said he said and it should be
known that Allah does not for prohibit
some
except through
wisdom and Allah does not prohibit
something except because it is
dangerous except because it is dangerous
then he
said he said it's possible that some
people are aware of the
wisdom and many people are not aw aware
of the
wisdom but the point is we realize that
Allah Asel does not prohibit something
except through wisdom and knowledge some
of us understand it and some of us don't
understand
it some of us understand it or some of
us don't understand it right but the
point is these things that are
prohibited such as comedy such as movies
such as cartoons and the likes look
where it's reached
now where they've entered uced it in
Disney movies in cartoons in comedy and
the likes and your
children men
women
have created such a liking for
it that now it's in the movies and the
comedy and the likes and they don't know
how to
stop they don't know how to
stop right did not our beloved Messenger
s wasam
said
the prophet sallallahu alhi wasallam
said who ever sees something wrong
change it with your hand if you can't
change it with your tongue if you can't
hate it in your heart and that is the
lowest level of Faith so what about our
Muslim brothers and sisters mothers and
fathers and children that see it on the
television they see it in the movie they
see it in the cartoon and they do
nothing about
it where is their level of Faith what
has happened to the hearts of the
Believers what has happened to the
hearts of the Believers another thing
and we'll make it the last thing and
we've cut through some of it because of
time but look at the absolute and this
is the last point that we'll
have and maybe tomorrow tomorrow's
lecture we'll begin with the remaining
part look at the absolute chaos and
utter confusion that it has caused in
the society and we'll just mention three
examples just mention three
examples because
islamically islamically there is a
ruling for these
individuals islamically there's a ruling
because they are a disease in the
society there are an illness in the
society so Islam has decreed something
they're pun pment not because they're
disbelievers as long as they feel that
they are sinning no but because they are
an illness in the society so one
example one example of chaos and turmoil
and that is force the
parents how many cases are in the courts
of America and England in Canada where
you have homosexual forer parents that
are raping their Force the
children raping their forc the children
this person has a
illness why would you give them the
ability to become Force the
parents right and the number of cases
that are in the courts now do not
reflect the number of cases that are
actually going on I'll say it again the
number of cases that are in the courts
do not reflect not even
near the amount of actual crimes that
are being committed
why because they have realized that the
forcer children are
afraid that if they inform about the the
the crimes that they will be placed back
where into the Forester home and the
forer children don't want to go back
into the Forester
home they've been neglected from their
parents they've been thrown away and now
they have forced the
parents that enjoy en Joy them like
toys so they're caught between can you
understand that
trauma you understand the extent of that
trauma that okay if you want to report
me which you go back into the forer home
so some forer children are not reporting
it out of fear of going back into the
forer
home Islam is the cure to the problems
of society that's one example the second
example and take this from an individual
who teaches in the prison
the problem in the
prisons individuals want to be
identified as women men want to be
identified as women so they put them
under the disguise of Human Rights and
civil rights and discrimination so they
put them in the prisons for
females so what happened they're getting
the female inmates
pregnant they're getting and taking this
form of personal teach teaches in prison
they're getting the female prisoners
pregnant because they're still men and
they still have masculine
desires and those women are females and
they have feminine
desires so they've noticed now that the
prisons that they're putting transgender
men transgender men are getting multiple
female inmates
pregnant and those females because they
get pregnant they don't get out of jail
they have their child in jail and their
jail the child is removed and placed in
a forer home look at the problem the
domino effect so what are they doing now
the problem's not finished CU I work in
a M's prison so they put them back into
the M's prison and then they become the
prostitutes in the male
prison so what do you
do what do you do it's an absolute
problem that's the second example the
third
example
Sports we know about that
the transgender men are want to go sport
they want to play sports but they want
to be identified as female so they put
them in swimming so a transgender man
competing against women so they're
taking all of the
medals so now the women are
complaining the women in the Olympics
and other sports don't talk about UFC
how they break the transgender men are
breaking the Jaws is thew of women of
course the physical makeup of a man is
stronger than a woman so now there's
problems in sports there's problems in
forer all there's problems in the
Department of Corrections why because
they're an illness to the
society these were just a few three
examples of the problems that these
individuals are causing in the
society tomorrow when we begin
tomorrow's lecture we mention some of
the things
that a Muslim family can do to combat
this illness in the society and to
protect yourself and your
family Allah
know